foreign
and welcome to rational science I'll be
met in a second by my son
and uh we're gonna get it started and
today we're going to open the floor
primarily for any questions that you
want to ask live
and we're going to try to answer them as
best as possible directly live meanwhile
uh I'm gonna do a little review of some
of the questions and comments people
made since last time
you're back I guess
um
regarding first Extinction
um and then some of the other issues
related to physics okay and I'll do a
little review of what we did this month
okay so let's get started first with the
extinction part there was some news this
week
space wars something like Star Wars this
is space wars okay and it goes more or
less like this they're worried about the
satellites and the news said Russian
China accused opposing's daily threat
from space they're worried that China
and Russia and some other countries
India North Korea et cetera
um are making
satellites that destroy satellites so if
a war comes to the Earth between the big
Powers they're going to be destroying
each other's satellites on the one hand
may not be such a bad idea because
without satellites I don't think you can
guide those nukes and and the other one
is that as you see there it says that um
you know they carry your Strike Force
um
operates thanks to all those satellites
okay but uh that final statement there
came from not the telegraph I think it
was the mirror of one of those Pentagon
warned world is moving closer to nuclear
war with Russia and China
do you think uh that's going to happen
do you think that is happening
did I uh start this right yeah yeah well
I thought maybe I wasn't uh streaming
for a second sorry folks I thought I
wasn't streaming for a second there okay
uh so we're gonna have a World War
um maybe world war or uh Newport let's
talk about nuke War are we gonna have a
nuke War
you know and uh if we kill the
satellites maybe it's not a bad idea
we'll ever get to a nuke or no you don't
think they'll throw them it's always a
possibility but I don't think
it'd be one of those things where it's
like I think that's that's just like an
admission that we're just gonna blow
everyone up no no no because it's like
uh if you can imagine this okay a
limited new Gore what do you mean uh I
throw and kill a million people if
you're there and you kill a million over
there and then the uh
uh heads of state or whoever the uh
Ministers of uh the uh exterior uh they
get together and they uh sign a treaty
and screw a million people what would be
the point in that well I don't know I
mean they say see the damage the Carnage
and they say well I think we should stop
the war the War lasted two minutes
no no you don't think that'll happen
there's no point to that well anyways uh
Food For Thought will there be a war
pentagon is saying that they will be uh
approaching a world a nuke War okay that
uh conflict is I guess is as the general
see it inevitable and again all these
countries every single one of them is
thinking about destroying the satellites
of the other country that makes sense
yeah yeah and that might not be so bad
if they do that first maybe we're all
safe you know
okay another issue fell a raise here
sentinelese I talked about that the
other day little uh Island over there in
the Indian Ocean and there's uh maybe
150 to 200 people there and they've
lived there for quite a while uh in the
19th century there were approximately 3
000 of them today there's only 150 to
200 and they hate anyone who comes to
their Island they're not very friendly
they kill anyone who approaches and uh
the theory is that they've been there
for sixty thousand years I showed the
map the other day when they come out of
Africa go all along the coast of India
and so on all the way to Australia and
some group you know decided to go to
this island
um and so this fellow asks us if these
Senegalese people are truly an isolated
60 000 plus year old tribe why are we
even studying fossils from that period
when we could just capture one of these
and study him or her and he's got a
point uh
I think he does I mean I don't think
you're gonna I mean if these people have
been around for 60 000 years on that
island yeah okay uh they must be
genetically completely isolated I don't
think that's the case I think these
people these sentinelies they've
probably been rushed into Neolithic I'd
say anywhere from three to ten thousand
years ago that's when they colonize the
island they've been there and as you can
see their population did not explode
today there's only 150 to 200
um I think they're on the way out
they're probably their genetic diversity
is shot their population pyramid has
apparently overturned but isn't this a
false correlation saying that I mean
there's a big difference between sixty
thousand years years ago uh skulls and
present skulls no matter where you find
them 60
000 years that doesn't mean that the
skull of the descendant of this person
is going to be the same as the person
yeah in other words you're saying that
these are not cro-magnons okay so even
if they've been on that which is what
this fellow was suggesting that maybe
they're Crow Magnus you know and in that
sense he's probably not right but uh in
a sense he is right in the sense that
if we could get one of these uh
individuals right you would think that
he's got such unique genetic uh code
that doesn't even match any uh any human
out there because they've been
supposedly isolated for 60 000 years I
don't think we would find that okay in
fact they took some of the other drives
around there which apparently are parent
or her sister or cousins of these you
know uh and uh their genetic code is not
that different from any of us have they
checked it yeah they checked it already
the the other uh tribes are which are a
little friendlier and have already uh
civilized some of their hair or what no
no they just did a genetic analysis to
find out you know these guys are you
know like from another planet no such
thing they're very they're very much
like us and so I would think that those
people on the island no change either I
think they're very much like us
that's my take how could that be if
they're such a if they've been on that
island isolated for so long yeah I'm
saying they haven't that's my point I
think they've been isolated maybe and I
don't even know if they've been
completely isolated because when I what
I read about them the English had
already visited them in the 19th century
gave them some of the you know coughed
at them killed a whole bunch uh through
some of the diseases the white man gave
this these black people okay and uh so
they've been in contact with with
civilization with civilizers civilized
with quotation civilized people uh but
the issue is that you know because of
that because they died and a lot of them
were kidnapping taken as trophies you
know like to show around oh I found one
of these uh you know natives from this
island and because of that I think they
they don't want to have anything to do
with us anymore that's why there's only
150 and there's only and that's why they
don't want anyone is in your Island Okay
so
I think they they haven't been around
for 60 000 Years anyway no I don't think
so no way okay a question about
neanderthals here fellow says I
guarantee if nandothal's fought modern
uh humans they kidnapped and raped the
women now that those were in Asia uh uh
too though right uh yeah you got to do a
little more research on the uh
neanderthals I'm saying that the
Neanderthals just like the denisovans
they look like more or less what you see
there I think they were kind of like
hairy gorillas maybe hairy men in some
way they had different facial features
and my argument is especially on the
denisovans they were so different than
us and the Neanderthals and you can see
it in their teeth their molars uh you
can see them up there on the uh on the
right hand side but they're on the left
the two left ones there then this is
about four and eight you can see there
molders are much bigger than the
Neanderthals or humans okay and that's
the same tooth compared there okay uh
part of the mouth being compared there
and you can see at the bottom uh if we
were to compare chimps uh the Australia
but the epithecus uh afarensis and
humans you can see that the afarensis
had bigger teeth than humans as well and
if you look at the denisigans they
probably match more afferences than they
did humans well aferences looked like
that guy on if you go to the left back
again the guy under the word denisovan
that's probably what they look like what
is the Denison have such short legs oh
okay that's the way I came out with them
you know like I'm with short legs really
creepy looking okay well next time I'll
try to do better wait you made that yeah
yeah that's nice yeah yeah you're
telling me
anyways I think the issue is the um the
teeth uh which I mean we only have three
molars they probably found them yeah of
the Denison we have three different
Boulders from three different
individuals one Splinter they they think
it's uh from uh bone in the leg or in
the arm it's like a longer Splinter so
they think it's from arm or leg and then
they have found a mandible in China uh
which they relate also to the denisovans
that's it that's all we have they blew
them up yeah you got a piece over there
piece over there that's it that's all we
have we don't have a skull we don't have
anything like that that guy got nuked
but but just judging by the molar you
can see that this this fellow and this
one was a monster I don't think even I
think even the Neanderthals would run
away
hahaha okay and another issue here
without says did the food chain that
feeds uh Plankton and land plants
collapse oh I like this and uh the
nitrogen or CO2 I guess no no it was uh
what I call the overturning of the
demographic pyramid for plants
yeah yeah if you want uh go ahead
and make this bigger yeah overturning of
the demographic pyramid oh I guess these
are two different things so we're
turning a demographic pyramid and
overturning of the ecological pyramid
the first one being
plants periodically become extinct when
they lose genetic diversity after
millions of years of inbreeding in their
population pyramid overturned so I guess
they get the same
um age-related Extinction that we do and
then the second one would be overturning
of the ecological pyramid the mechanism
of a mass extinction which I guess is
where the Predators get so uh numerous
that they outnumber the ones that they
feed on and then so on and so forth yeah
in other words uh you have the many
chasing after the few as I like to say
uh you know uh it's it's uh this pyramid
what collapses is really the um primary
production the plants that they eat in
the case of the Plankton uh you know
there's phytoplankton and zooplankton
there's animal Plankton and and plant
plankton
and so uh you know uh that begins to
disappear what I showed last time I'm
going to show that again uh is that at
the end of Cretaceous the turnover from
the Cretaceous to the tertiary what
you'll see there is that what died were
big the dinosaur uh Plankton before a
minifora were they that big no no not
that big but but I showed a picture
there anymore oh what was there before
the KT boundary what died at the KT
boundary were the big forums you know
the diamonds and so on they were big
what came after very tiny and that's
expected when you when you have a mass
extinction because what happens is you
know there's these little fellas in the
background that maybe nobody eats maybe
they're too small I'm not sure the
reason uh or maybe they occupied
different niches or maybe they're in a
different region of the planet I don't
know the exact issue but the the point
is that the what died were the big
Plankton that had been around for
millions of years it had grown to be
there the dinosaurs of the Seas uh so to
speak of of the Plankton world and what
replaced them were those that radiated
after the big guys were gone and who and
who ate the uh forums the ammonites and
who ate the amanus the mosasaurs uh
that's one food chain obviously there
were more food chains that's one food
chain all three disappear Now isn't that
a coincidence you mean the one that fed
on yeah for them that whole food chain
yeah I got two questions yeah the first
one is we talked a lot about the
extinction of planktons are they like
the bottom of each food chain it's hard
it's wrong each food chain yeah I would
say that in the seas in the Seas I think
that uh Plankton is is the bottom line
you have also algae remember algae is
also like the food chain the bottom of
the food chain so you have algae playing
through all the small stuff and that's
what all the I guess the next level size
animals in the Seas eat and then the
next one yes it's a size issue the
bigger you are the more powerful you are
the more you can eat is there a
difference between land and water water
plants like yeah they die at the same
time no that's the that's in fact the
question that I always pose there okay
let me put that up there
um this is the homework question I
always like to put up there why do the
animals on land disappear more or less
at the same time as the animals in the
seasons yeah they more or less die at
the same time and the question is for
you right
uh no because it happened in all mass
extinctions so I think it's a law of
Mother Nature what you got to figure out
is why
chain connects Land and Sea I guess is
uh one guy mentioned that last time no I
don't think that's the answer but nice
try but I mean if if we're talking about
different food chains right yeah we're
talking there's a food chain in the sea
and food chain and on land yeah
they're not really they're not related
so why would they die at the same time
good good that's Food For Thoughts
that's what we have here you for what do
you mean I don't know I'm not going to
tell you that one because that's what I
want people to think about if you can if
you can answer that question you have a
very good clue of how mass extinctions
work why they work you know at the same
time why do the land animals die more or
less geologically speaking remember
you're talking about maybe thousands of
years different fine but I mean more or
less they die at the same time they
disappear at the same time unland
indices in the air all at the same time
why
and uh I'm not going to give you the the
answer I want you to uh that's a great
thing yeah that's a great teacher and we
will tell you I went to the brainstorm
until your brain boils yeah food web not
food chain that's I guess a better way
yeah I think it's a web also more than a
chain that's true because it changes you
the idea that it's linear where this is
kind of you know spread out right yeah
it's I would agree with that better name
for it okay in the news this week in the
news sounds like a spider Buffet though
it's not your particle notice the Tetra
Quark was discovered
uh it's a new particle they say they
discovered do I have to read this yeah
if you want
today the lhcb experiment at CERN is
presenting a new discovery at the
European physical Society conference on
high energy physics the new particle
discovered by lhcb labeled as
something is a tetraquark an exotic
hadron containing two quarks and two
antiquarks it is the longest lived
exotic matter particle ever discovered
and the first to contain two heavy
quarks and two light anti-quarks yeah
it's uh we're full of quarks I think the
the people who are quarks uh other
people are concerned they're very quirky
you know uh
um hold on real quick real quick just
from a a Layman's point of view I
thought Cork and anti-core anytime you
have a thing an anti thing if they're
next to each other they negate each
other they
annihilate yeah so are they breaking
their own rules oh come on they never
break Turtles okay but off the bat like
that would be my first goal I wish we
had the guy who did that here so I could
ask him for questions they come I mean
my question is uh what sense does it
continue to make uh for these people
just to discover new particles so we
discover a new particle and then a new
particle and then all we do is just name
new particles and it's like I'm gonna
say really at the end that uh we don't
know what these particles look like I'm
not saying that no I mean I do but it's
got to be uh being awesome father who's
going to speak for us there and and what
she says is
um that we can't see these part we've
never seen these particles so we don't
see these particles we see a trace of
something
and we don't see the particle or the
thing that made the trace what we see is
the hole through the gas okay we see a
trace in the gas and we say oh that was
made by a particle this Trace is also uh
kind of what do you call it yeah you're
making a lot of assumptions yeah it's
leading the witness kind of like like
was it a trace or was it like a whip
that hit it yeah
right right and so there might just be
one thing and they've only considered
traces they say we're looking at traces
I'm saying if that's true it'd be very
easy to just to put your ruler across
the picture that you've taken right and
know the diameter of that particle right
because if the if the trace is made by a
particle at least you've got the
diameter and they say these particles
are Zero Dimensional Point particles so
what the hell are they talking about if
they say particle and here they have a
trace and it's got at least uh yeah they
should be at least be able to put the
ruler across that that's simple I can do
that you know that's one that's one I
don't know about the other two
Dimensions but at least has the width
yeah you got at least the diameter of
the particle and if you've got a
gazillion something you just put your
ruler on each one you'll say okay the
muon has so many so much uh you know
whatever uh microns or nanometers you
know you measure you you put the values
and they say all these particles are
Zero D I really wonder how it must be to
be a guy working and start doing this
stuff like are they excited to go to
work or is it just like another thing to
give name to
it's it's what I used to do in a way we
had what is called implanters at uh
Advanced Micro Devices all these
semiconductor companies and you
accelerate particles or so they think
they're doing that okay and in our case
we accelerated not hadrons or or
electrons what we accelerated were ions
okay big ions we weren't doing uh you
know like a hydrogen ion now we were
doing uh phosphorus or Boron okay we
were accelerating those and uh you know
uh bombarding the Wafers with those ions
okay fine the question is you know we
went every day what did we talk about we
talked about energy
okay we had the Keb I worked at the Kev
killer electron boat these guys work at
the Giga and Terra electron vote I was
very simple very you know but the the
the mechanism is the same it says that I
worked at the killer electron volt but
the but the whole process is the same
thing you accelerate and you look at
what is the energy well this is the
energy and this was the mass we talked
in those terms those are the words we
use okay but uh when you say well how
big is the particle you know we never
asked that question we never heard
how big is the phosphorus atom I mean
nobody cared about that and we just said
what is your energy oh your energy is
too low that's why it didn't work right
so it raised your energy you know that's
why you were also trying to produce a
result so you didn't need to know well
these two big these people in a way they
don't have to produce a result okay but
there's there's a difference in
but seeing a way what they want to look
at is the salt in their in their gas
chain in their bubble chamber they they
want to look at what happens inside that
that region where they can map okay they
can they actually do it with computers
it's not like there's a guy with a
snapshot there you know taking pictures
no ah you missed it it was too bad no
they do it they do it with uh computers
because just do fast and and they treat
everything the computer is already
programmed to treat everything as a
particle and as a trace so you know no
surprise there hey you know we found a
new particle yeah because you called it
a particle because you already
programming your computer that it's a
particle okay so every blip is a
particle they don't know what that blip
is but they just call it a particle and
uh and so yeah they go to work and they
accelerate all this stuff but they they
never see the thing that they're
accelerating assuming they're
accelerating something okay all they do
is just uh play around with the energy
they look at the traces and they say oh
this one's different I'm I'm going to
call this one Charlie and the other
one's Johnny and this one's Tommy that's
all it is and it's just naming new stuff
and getting their names and lights you
know because they play around with the
energy and if they increase the energy
the force whatever the mass the charge
well what happens they get a different
result and they say oh I've never seen
that line before I'm going to call this
one Charlie
that's all it is and so it's just naming
traces and have they ever shown a
picture of any other in their in their
you know in their papers they say we
discovered a new particle okay what does
it look like it looks like this see here
it is it's beautiful it's uh red uh you
know it's got little pointers on the
outside you never see a particle all
they do is give you the equation they
say this is so much mass this is so much
charge that's it and that's why they say
it's a different particle because it's
got different charge or mass or whatever
than a particle they discovered 10 years
ago okay but when they have news like
this you know great uh
news like who gets excited over this
stuff or is it just to give the science
report or something to write in a way it
is uh just that because let me tell you
something any technology is made with
anything atom or above you don't make
you don't make uh things with sub atomic
particles okay that's the first one and
then all they're trying to do is as
they're trying to understand that secret
world but they're not trying to really
explain it what they're trying to do is
they say oh we discovered this new
particle this new thing and why because
all they can do is describe it in terms
of energy charge mass and all these
mathematical Concepts but have they seen
a particle do they know it's a particle
no they don't especially when they tell
you it's zero and I mentioned on their
point particles Elementary particles
fundamental particles whatever the word
they use they're talking about a nothing
in non-existing entity that made a trace
we got two answers to your homework
already oh okay that's it yeah go ahead
this is talking about the extinction of
plant life on in the water and plant
life on Earth okay let's go with it
the first one is plants are ultimately
dependent on the carbon nitrogen
hydrogen sulfur and other Cycles
biological pumps cause minute changes
over millions of years
I guess it's a Environmental
the second one being is the answer to
your homework question about the Sun or
ground nutrients Earth's surface
nutritionally reaches critical mass
approximately globally and needs to
reboot thus Land and Sea dies becoming
Barren and Lush cyclically just like any
other natural cycle
um I think these carbon and nitrogen
Cycles have nothing to do with them
that's my my take on that and what was
uh that was the first one then the
second one was uh I got stuck there uh
Sun nutrients is the answer to your
whole question about the Sun or ground
nutrients I'm not sure what uh what he's
referring to there
I'm gonna die here okay shouldn't drink
on the stream but let me okay so uh no I
disagree with both uh but okay that was
a quote from why God doesn't exist
trying to understand the extinction at
the same time this one plants are
ultimately dependent on the carbon
nitrogen hydrogen and sulfur yeah but
that's not the cause
I don't know maybe that was a
misunderstanding yeah that they rely on
these things is true uh but that's not
the cause of why plants and
animals well animals in the sea die at
the same time as those on land and
plants as well let's say I'm saying yeah
they rely on the cycle no doubt about
that
but that's got nothing to do with why
they die at the same time that's my
point okay well that's my argument okay
let's move on here uh another uh
in the news uh am I reading this one too
yeah go ahead if you want to hold let me
get this I
need a new spin on planet formation
Mysteries these spin measurements are
consistent with the picture of magnetic
braking regulating the spins of giant of
gas giant planets during the planet
formation process when combining these
rotation measurements with literature
rotation measurements of sub Stellar
companions as well as our solar system
gas giants we found a tentative trend of
increasing rotation rate with decreasing
Planet Mass they could point to Magnetic
braking
being less efficient for lower Mass
planets what are they saying okay
what they're talking about is the
following they're trying to explain
um you know how planets form and they're
not talking about little tiny planets
like uh Mercury or even Earth they're
talking about macro planets like Jupiter
and Saturn and even bigger ones ones
that really are small stars that never
got to ignite but we're talking about
the spin of the plan yeah and they're
saying that uh between the study of
their magnetism the magnetic field and
their spin they're looking at all these
parameters and they're trying to figure
out how these planets form because
they're trying to figure out how Jupiter
formed essentially or confirm that it's
through this uh nebular hypothesis
version of plant information
Cloud that's rotating as it rotates you
know it like the skater you know it
closes in their arms well this
gravitationally all this gas comes
together and forms eventually this ball
this is the
hypothesis the nebular hypothesis and
they say this is how our sun form
I have no problem with stars okay I have
no problem that that's how the Sun could
have formed I think it could have been a
uh big giant cloud of gas that rotated
rotates because of gravity the gravity
pulls every atom inwards and eventually
it condenses into this ball we call the
Sun and then it continues through
billions of years to to compress
compressed compressed compress and
create light like our sun does that's
different than a planet like a rocky
planet like the Earth Venus Mercury Mars
Pluto or any other small one like you
take Ceres which is the largest asteroid
out there it's a it's a ball it looks it
looks like this okay it looks like a
perfect ball if you look at it and I'm
saying anything that is a perfect ball
out there was a son was a star okay and
uh what you'll notice that uh for
example the Earth is differentiated it's
got all these different layers and it
goes from the more heavy elements
towards the center to the lighter ones
on the outside to the point where you
get to the gases on the outside nitrogen
oxygen that's what our air is made out
of what am I describing a star
in the center it's heavy and the outside
it got silicone and eventually oxygen
and so on and when you look at all these
uh round planets out there or around
objects it will come Celestial logic
because Ceres is an asteroid but a lot
of them are differentiated and again
they're differentiating the pro in the
right way they've got the heavy elements
on the inside and the lighter ones on
the outside and then why are they so
round well it was gravitationally
um chiseled okay it was compressed
that's why it ends it up as a round ball
radially yeah yeah that's the only way
you can do it so anything that's round
out there was a star now in the case of
Jupiter it could have been could have
been the nebular hypothesis because it's
still a gas uh ball that's all it is but
what you got to explain is not the gas
ball which is the one we're always
fascinated with you gotta explain for
example the Galilee and
why is Iowa why is uh Europa why are
those rocky planets if they if if
Jupiter was part of that cloud of gas
that formed the sun why do the moons of
Jupiter why are they Iraqi if they're at
the same uh distance from the Sun you
would think that everything uh either
turns into gas or everything turns into
little balls and here you have these
moons they're Rocky moons like uh our
moon like Mercury you know all these are
rocky uh planets or things uh celestial
objects and they're next to this gases
planted uh called Jupiter same thing
versus Saturn same thing for Uranus and
Neptune so that's what when people talk
about the nebular hypothesis I want to
go to the moons of Jupiter or to Saturn
Jupiter's gaseous but the moons are
rocky please tell me why and they're at
the same distance from the Sun so but in
my opinion uh Jupiter could have formed
from a nebular hypothesis because it's
still a star information never will
ignite probably it's too too small
but uh yeah but you got to explain the
rocky moons it's got that's that's where
I'm maybe Jupiter is our backup son when
the sun explodes we got Jupiter to turn
into the Sun or we can run away to to
Jupiter okay let's move on here
uh another uh in the news this week and
this has to do with and this has to do
with uh uh light bending x-ray Echoes
from behind a super massive black hole
what what does the title even mean well
it says that light is coming they they
finally discovered for the first time
that's why it was in the news uh
emissions from behind the black hole
they're saying that the black hole is
throwing uh uh light from behind it and
we can't see behind it because we can't
see through the black holes but the
light turns around it turns around yeah
and it comes all the way to our eyes so
they said that these emissions are from
behind and the reason they claim that
it's that that is the case is that the
black hole is rotating rotating and so
because it rotates what happens is the
front part let's say it rotates uh from
uh left to right okay so uh from above
it's a rotating counterclockwise okay we
got that yeah and so and so it's going
like this right
when it comes to you
it should be blue shifted whatever is
coming to you the light should be blue
shifted and when it goes away it should
be red shifted and that's why it's
coming towards us and the right side is
going away from us and and so they say
it's the light from behind because the
thing is rotating and as it comes you
have this uh they know it's the light
from the black hole they say because as
it comes towards you it's blue Shifting
the one that's going away is red
that's how they figure that out and so
the big news was Black Hole uh is
emitting light from behind now this
contradicts everything we had from uh
from the 60s on black holes that uh you
know nothing escapes a black hole
especially light you know because uh
everything at the Event Horizon is
sucked inwards at the speed of light I
guess or greater I don't know if maybe
it's maybe it breaks though
but the point is at least the speed of
light that's why they say they talk
about escape velocity okay they just the
escape Velocity city is little C and uh
no uh my friend Steven
crowthers has something to say about
that you can look up his uh work out
there and uh he'll tell you that it's
nonsense to talk about escape velocity
out of the Event Horizon I agree but
that's a long story anyways the point
here is that they discover that light
coming from behind the black hole from
from its behind and the question is what
is a black hole don't tell me about the
light coming out of it which already it
makes no sense because that's why we
call it a black hole because nothing can
escape and then they came up with the
Hawking radiation you know the particle
breaks into the space particle breaks
into positive and negative one falls in
the other one comes out and reaches your
eye I don't know why why that one
doesn't fall in as well you know so a
lot of this nonsense that they have out
there but the point is what is a black
hole to begin with it's a zero
Dimensions
[Music]
it's a Zero Dimensional Singularity
surrounded by some a concept known as an
event horizon the hole in space is it a
sphere what are we talking about yeah
what what are we talking about that's
about but essentially what did they see
they saw uh blue shifted and redshifted
right that's it and they say but they
concluded from that but then we can
maybe assuming that's correct then we
can conclude that something is spinning
there maybe maybe what if there's
nothing spinning and it's what I'm
saying it is which it has to do with the
uh magnetic lines
through that region
okay and what you have in that region is
is gases we can't see the gases from
here I mean you know you can't detect
that but what you have is the magnetic
lines of force in this case the threads
going through those gases just at Great
speeds you're talking about the galactic
uh could be from another star nearby
also and they're going right through
that region and that's what's uh
sparking that region and giving you the
impression that there's something there
other than gases that's a nice uh word
combination Galactic magnetism that
sounds that sounds nice that's a nice
band name okay let's move on here let me
do a recap of what we did this month
real quick Oh I thought that was the
reason
this is the recap we did uh quantum
mechanics and we looked at a lot of the
properties that uh they discovered in
quantum mechanics uh we have
superposition what is superposition well
superposition is a horse gallops and
stance still at the same time time okay
so how they manage that we don't know
but they say the particle vibrates and
it doesn't vibrate at the same time
that's when you're really sleepy but
drink a lot of coffee isn't it uh
Schrodinger's cat
um you know you got to peek Inside the
Box otherwise the cat meanwhile is both
dead and alive and that was an analogy
for what uh well that's Schrodinger
invented this uh Urban Schrodinger he
invented this analogy to explain what
these people the people from The
Copenhagen interpretation which was
primarily Neosporin Werner Heisenberg
what they were saying is he was saying
this is what these guys are saying about
the microscopic World about the
subatomic world that it's like if you
have a cat the cat is both dead and
alive until you Peak and that's why we
have that you know the All-Seeing Eye
there you gotta look inside the box to
find out if it's dead or alive at that
point as soon as you look as soon as you
interfere with the experiment at that
point collapses to either dead or alive
but meanwhile it's in both States I'm
sure the spirits were spiritualist had a
field day with this one Consciousness
changes matter essentially that's why
that's why these people talk about
Consciousness lady a lot because they
eventually end up getting out of physics
and talking about well that's what this
is actually they're saying with
Consciousness within Iowa the witness
we're changing reality just just by
having an eye on something the cat is
either alive or dead yeah and the issue
here is that they put the Observer at
the center of the whole process so if
the guy's drunk or is on high uh you
know he got to rely on his testimony
okay then we go into spin what a spin
well the spin is also more or less they
have all these dualities and in the case
of spin the uh the dancer spins
clockwise and counterclockwise at the
same time again it's all these dualities
that they have what was this in relation
to they say all particles spin but they
have all these dual spins until you put
your uh measurement device there and
then it collapses through either
clockwise or counterclockwise and again
spin is not spin they're these two
dancers are spinning that's not what
these people are talking about when they
say spin they're talking about something
completely different and it's got to do
with orientation it's like yeah at that
point what they're looking at is they
put a line on the ball depending on when
you look the line is is pointing a
different direction and that's how you
can tell by how much time passed how
much it turned or yeah no what they're
saying is Imagine imagine this you can
explain it very well with a rope in fact
let's do it here we're going to do this
experiment so very dangerous experiment
put your hand crosswise no crosswise
like cutting your leg Yeah so that yeah
that's okay
okay so so it's like that so uh show the
screen now
okay so he cut it there okay so that's
what he gets he gets that cross section
right there
okay now if you move a little then it
changes it changes the the curvature I
guess where the two circles are right
right essentially with a rope you can
explain what these people think about as
spin because what they're doing is doing
a cross-section at a given point see the
way they they measure these things is
with an ellipsometer or something
comparable to an ellipsometer which is
what I use in the industry and that is
at some point where you have the
detector at that point it's the
cross-section of light whatever light's
going there it's like you're cutting
light if you have a laser going through
there it cuts the laser at that point
and at that point it's got to give an
orientation they say oh that's spin it's
been one that's when it's been half this
one's been minus one that's what they
call these things and all you're doing
is you know if you move along that line
and that rope you'll find different
orientations of the Rope that's more or
less what these people call spin that's
that's the best thing that I can give
you as far as what spin means to them
it's a static concept not a dynamic one
like you know like a spinning top that's
my point okay from there we moved to
tunneling and tunneling looks like this
you have the snowball and it goes
through the mountain but the way it does
it it turns into a wave and then it
appears on the other side so from one
side of the mountain to the other side
it goes instantaneously because you know
the the the part that goes through the
mountain does it is a wave and it
appears on the other side they call that
tunneling are they saying photons go
from
and electrons yeah they go from a ball a
particle to a wave when it goes through
something and then back into a particle
essentially that's their explanation
what they're saying is the snowball
appears on the other side of the
mountain instantaneously as if the
mountain weren't there
so there's distance but there's no
mountain but what's the snowball talking
about exactly no it could be photons or
it could be electrons so think of a
snowball as an electron so they're
saying this electron the mountain is
what is a barrier some an energy barrier
what do you mean by energy like a break
uh not quite it's mathematics it's just
an energy barrier and it turns out it's
a barrier that's sufficient to prevent
the uh electron from going through and
the electron does go through but it goes
instantaneously through the entire
barrier through the entire energy
barrier as if the barrier weren't there
so they said go through there faster
than the speed of light yeah and the
only way they can explain it is they say
well you know somehow it stretches its
neck across the mountain and it appears
on the other side how did they figure
this out
when did they just calculate this no
yeah it's a is this an experiment or a
calculation this is a calculation
performed on an experiment they have to
answer the experiment and they say we
see it on the other side we don't know
why but this is the calculation and from
the calculation comes the theory and the
theory is that somehow the particle
appears on the other side which is so
far a description and the way they try
to get around it is saying well you know
remember that uh an electron just like a
photon is not only a particle it's also
a wave that's just cheating yeah so they
turned it into a way what was the
experiment well they've got several
experiments where they verified this
Behavior okay where where they have this
energy barrier and they have the
electron and they have electricity right
flowing through there and there's this
energy barrier and somehow electricity
gets the word energy barrier yeah well I
know there's no other way to another
question mark what do you mean what is
actually going through I had to put the
mountain because people understand
mountains people don't understand an
energy barrier okay so because it
doesn't mean anything I know it's a
mathematical concept and they're saying
there's this energy this wall of energy
whatever you want to think of it as I
put in a mountain so that you can
understand physically what's going on
and they're saying that this electric
electricity is going through there they
put this energy barrier and the
electricity and under certain
circumstances goes right through and the
only way they can explain how
electricity how that electron because
electricity is the flow of electrons how
it got through that energy barrier is by
turning it into a wave that stretches
its neck across and they say oh see
that's how it ended instantaneously on
the other side of the energy barrier and
so the only way I can illustrate that is
with a mountain and saying you know the
ball of the snowball went through the
mountain as a wave and that's how it
appears on the other side
that's it take it or leave it
okay like invoking magic don't they yeah
they do okay and then moving on here we
have
um the Moss bar effect is the other one
and that's recoilless emission okay and
what is that about well Moss bar said
you know
um uh when you have uh the atom is in
the lattice like in a crystal lattice
and it shows these gamma rays out there
it's got to be with high frequency gamma
rays uh there's no recoiling or none
that they can measure which is a
probably a better way of putting that
none that they can measure and they say
there's essentially recoil these
recoilless emission and the folks at the
Harvard Tower experiment they uh use
that uh unknown that phenomena that uh
observation that they cannot explain
they use it for the Harvard Tower
experiment where they showed that
gravity pulls on light okay which was I
didn't get it over this guy did okay and
all I'm saying on that uh is that this
is what uh Moss bar was really looking
at without knowing he's got a rope tied
to that atom and again if it's a bigger
atom than a hydrogen we're going to have
many ropes okay
it's the same thing is uh what we have
is that there is no such thing as a wave
okay wave is a verb you got to identify
the thing that is waving and that's
where uh Moss bar failed as well you
know like all others because they don't
have a a physical entity in there okay
it's just a good foundation yeah they
have his math all they have is just uh
you know all this math and they try to
get it away with just a um what they say
is a physical interpretation when you
put them against the wall and they say
we don't understand it either and
anyways that's uh philosophy anyways so
why did they try in the first place I
like apply math to the Rope model like
if you could calculate the torsion of a
rope it doesn't fit the exact the the
equations are all out there you look for
uh equations for torsion it's all been
done uh so you know I don't do math I I
did a lot of math when I was in college
but I don't care about math but those
people who want to know how fast or all
that stuff they can calculate all that
stuff by going to the equations for
torsion and they're all out there and
you can calculate the speed of light you
can figure out what the torsion is on
the Rope okay if you're interested go
ahead and look up get a noble for that
yeah you might get a noble you never
know hey guys I proved the Rope
hypothesis
okay uh Ray reversibility next one on
the line
um what was that all about well I put
that in my real physics uh cartoons
there and essentially light retraces its
exact path that's why you see yourself
every piece of your body is mirrored in
the mirror okay and uh when you send
light through up
um lens uh light goes right through the
lens coming back along the same lines
how do you explain that that's a really
nice gift I like the top right one yeah
how do you uh how do you explain this
with uh particles I mean don't they get
lost
you would you would think they do right
and uh so
this is uh the lunar ranging experiment
that um
you could say the same thing here how do
they do this with the lunar ranging
experiment if light travels exactly in a
straight line well it turns out that you
know they have to shoot the light in
front of where the the moon is going to
be in one second because the Moon is
1.25 light seconds away from us like 300
000 a little more 380 I think it is 380
a thousand kilometers away that means
light takes 1.25 seconds to get there
and to come back it's two and a half
seconds what does that mean it means
that in order to do this uh light has to
travel completely straight because
that's what Ray reversibility says it
does and what these people do is they
say they shoot the laser where the moon
is going to be in one second and uh
remember that in one second the Earth
moves 30 kilometers around the Sun and
the moon moves one kilometer around the
earth that means both objects moved in
space so how is it that the photon went
and came back the other argument is that
they send gazillions of photons out from
this powerful laser okay and uh what
comes back what what returns is just a
handful maybe 20 photons that's what
they detect in the uh in their computers
in there you know because they they have
these detectors and they turn that into
signals and they have these Peaks that
they look at and they say okay here's a
peak that came from that laser and I'm
gonna get to that in a second because a
person asks a question about that okay
and so uh let me hold off on that
explanation for a few seconds here and
let me get to that final one and that's
the magnetic lines of force which I
covered the other day and let's see if I
can find it here here it is
ah
I'm lost
uh where is this
went all the way to the other side
that's what happened
foreign
belongs
okay so uh the next one is that magnetic
lines of force and uh what a magnetic
lines of force where else these here
okay that uh I showed the other day
okay and uh when you put two magnets
together they're magnet their lines of
force uh merge somehow and uh lines of
force go around both magnets as if it
were a single magnet that's what happens
with the lines of force and we know this
only because we sprinkle
um iron filings over them so if you
sprinkle iron filings over two magnets
and get them eventually together they
act as a single magnet and a line of
force goes around both of them okay we
have to explain that what are those
lines of force well they never figured
it out they say those are abstract
they're not real uh they're imaginary
but it turns out that these imaginary
lines of force not only move iron file
names but they are called lines of force
meaning they cause forces and how can
they affect things in the real world in
our three-dimensional world like iron
filings if they're imaginary and so this
is what uh they never answered they
never answered that question okay and so
what can I say we don't have an answer
at least from Quantum Mechanics for for
bytes of force they don't know what
magnetism is well so we don't know any
of those things we don't know uh
superposition we don't know uh spin we
don't know lines of foreign
reversibility we don't know nothing from
Quantum the mathematical physicists
don't know nothing there's a lot of
nobles to be had yeah and so we had
hundreds need to find more particles in
fact we had 120 years of Nobel prizes
and we have so much ignorance and they
say well we're still investigating what
are you investigating I mean this is an
issue of identifying the invisible
actors that's all it is once you
identify the invisible actors all this
is kindergarten stuff and I'm saying
exactly that kindergarten it's kids
stuff even then it isn't but it is it is
because it's what I say if you see a guy
pulling on a box and the Box goes up and
you and you don't see anything else you
say oh he did that by Magic it turns out
that you know you didn't see the robe
that's tied around the invisible pulley
but if if I show you the pulley and the
Rope that's tied to the box and that
guy's pulling on on the Rope through the
pulley
that's anybody can understand hands I
see everything there yeah but
only because you cannot see the rope and
the pulley you think the boss went up by
Magic and you say how can they do it and
all you do is describe mathematics you
know Well the box has so much weight and
it went up at such and such speed and
that's all these people do no no I want
you to identify the rope and the pulley
in in quantum mechanics that's what we
need and that's what's never been done
in 120 years but but how many motions
does an atom have off wheels
okay uh yeah vibrate it vibrates
okay and that's put them all together
you got a vibrating pumping moving back
and forth sliding on an abacus yeah yeah
uh the shell of the atoms slithering
around you got a lot of things going you
got the magnetism line there's a lot of
emotions okay that's true but at the
same time if you were able to see it all
you would say okay I see what's
happening here you know what light is
it's a torsion of a room if you saw an
engine moving there's a lot of motion
still no no but
if you see it all it's still pretty hard
okay but let's look at the simple stuff
let's let's just look at light yeah and
I'm saying look light is a torsion and
and if you were able to have the eyes of
God of the devil of Mother Nature father
Universe one of those guys and you would
see the Rope just twirling
and you would stare it for a while say
okay I understand what light is light is
just the torsion along this object it
would be no mystery it's because we
cannot see the mediator of light people
say oh what is light let's measure let's
see the speed oh must have been a
particle that went from here to there
now if it's a torsion and you see the
robe and you see it all there you would
say oh so stupid of me believing it was
a particle or a wave uh transfers wave
you know moving up and now once you see
the Ruby oh okay that's so stupid so
simple and yeah there are other motions
that you gotta count for of course okay
um here's um
attraction and repulsion okay oh okay
and uh the top one is attraction the
bottom one is repulsion and what you
yeah no they're not if you look one is
going clockwise the two on the top are
going counterclockwise okay so you got
to look at the atoms there and you can
see that they're both going
counterclockwise they're both going this
way see yeah and then the one on the
bottom we've turned the first one around
it's going clockwise yeah okay so if you
look at that very closely you see the
line what I call Serpentine a line of
merged electron shells and the ones at
the bottom they're moving in contrary
directions okay they're moving like this
the ones on the top they're moving both
in the same direction so uh it's those
lines of force
the threads right that move and connect
with the lines of force of the other uh
Serpentine this could be two wires this
could be two magnets it doesn't matter
but the point is that it's something
physical there that we can't see or
touch something very tenuous okay if if
we could see a thread that makes up the
Rope you'd be surprised how small how
thin it is okay but this is essentially
the mechanism I'm proposing and at least
you can understand it whether you
believe in it or not it's a separate
issue but the point is here you have an
understanding of Attraction and
repulsion the first one being conveyor
belt the second one being like drier
squeezer but yeah it's like I say two
rollers of a washing machine of the old
days you know where you put your shirt
between them the two rollers went in the
um in opposite directions right and
squeeze the shirt through there that's
what it's like a dough maker they also
have that yeah they've used it for
different things in out there you know
it's easier to to give them names like
uh again the conveyor belt versus no
okay I I caught the the what is the
machine dryer the machine the dryer of
the old days right two two rollers
drying the shirt
okay so someone asked out there okay
said uh
no you want to read them maybe
in your green animation of lines of
force rotating at approximately
27.58 yeah that's uh the time yeah uh
why are the lines of force not drawn
connected to each connected each to
every other okay I see I would have
expected each green ball to have a line
of force to every other green ball why
would the lines of force look like they
do with the iron filings and not in any
other way as explained by your rope
model yeah simplified it yeah yeah
essentially this should be very simple
I'm saying that the line these lines of
force are really the trajectories of the
threads that are spinning around they're
spinning around because the uh the merge
the electron shells of different atoms
are also spinning around or aligned
spinning around and Swinging these
threads around that's what creates the
lines the these lines of force that
compel iron filings to a line along the
lines of force that's that's all is
they're sweeping right through them so
the the the
um
threads are not connected to threads the
threads are connected to these talking
about why isn't there a line of force
between each two green balls isn't the
simple answer that you simplified it
that's technically true yeah you can't
draw the gazillions of uh threads there
all you want to understand the mechanism
the mechanism you know that's because it
wasn't clear yeah simplified it the the
mechanism is that you you have merged
electron shells of say iron okay and
iron's a complex uh
Adam could begin with you know I've
shown
pictures of iron uh in the past and
emerge they merge the electron shells
emerge they overlap yeah and and what
happens is they blend okay and what
happens is they're aligned and now
they're going to spin if it's magnetized
if it's magnetized they're going to spin
if it's not if it's just Standard Iron
and it's not going to spin okay and so
if they're spinning when they when they
spin they swing around the uh threads
not only that interconnect the atoms but
also that form the electron shells they
come out and they form these uh walls of
threads that swing around and when you
have two of these from one magnet and
another one uh wire Live Wire and
another Live Wire they these threads are
the ones that uh interact with each
other if they're moving in the same
direction you know one one uh pulls on
the other if they're moving the opposite
direction they they slap each other yeah
they slap each other and push each other
away and that's the repulsion those are
the mechanisms uh you you have to use
your imagination you can even draw it
yourself I did quite a few uh videos on
this you can look them up but you can
draw them yourself to try to visualize
what I'm explaining do you believe it
that's a separate issue I'm saying I can
explain to you how a magnet attracts and
how a magnet repels another okay through
this mechanism that's all I'm saying and
what is the menu when you turn it around
obviously you know you're going to
change from clockwise to
counterclockwise and now you're you're
going to either
repulse or attract so so the mechanism
right there is right there and that
gives me at least confidence that that's
probably how Mother Nature is doing it
okay but you don't have to agree with me
but at least understand the mechanism
okay and uh wenpo along the same lines
because we talked about that the other
day
and um he he asked the following let me
put let me put here and
the electrostatic lines of force are
really lines the magnetic are not lines
but loops they are closed in itself the
electrostatic are not yeah what the
fellow is saying is that uh magnets uh
have these lines these electric these
magnetic lines and they're Loops whereas
the electric lines they say they stretch
straight out of the charge that's what
this is what the guy is referring to so
he's saying magnetic lines are not the
same thing as electric lines this is
what he's saying okay I'll address that
in a second uh just keep reading there
in the case of a current carrying wire
the magnetic lines are not connected to
anything but in itself how this fit with
your atom to atom connection Treads I
guess threads yeah don't forget the
electrified wires are not equal solid
magnets please note the pattern yeah
this is what he's saying he's saying
that uh magnetic and electric are not
the same
and uh it's the same effect but
different uh causes yeah well he's
saying that they're not even the same
effect he's saying they're different
he's saying this essentially here's the
repulsion pattern and he's saying no
circles that you see there he's saying
that those are not attached to anything
okay you can see the circles they're
going around they're not touching the
wire they're going around the wire so
he's saying those circles those hula
hoops those rings
are standalone well if they're
Standalone why can't you bring a ring to
the conference room uh to the next
conference okay if it's true they're
independent from The Wire they can't be
independent from The Wire because then
you would be able to have a magnet a
magnet magnetic lines without the magnet
you would get rid of the magnet and you
would have a field you never have just
the magnetic field it's always the the
what the effect of some cause right this
fella thinks that uh these lines of
force that make up the magnetic lines of
force he thinks they're hula hoops that
he thinks they're rings that he can pull
them out and they're not tied to
anything they're standing that's how
they're always drawn yeah but they're
not they have to be tied to something
because otherwise you would be able to
have a uh a magnetic field which is made
of all these rings without the magnet
without the Live Wire you could have it
without that and you can't you need
something material in order to have a
magnetic field in order to have magnetic
lines of Force so this notion that you
have that their Rings is what's uh
irrational okay so let's look at that
let's look at in more detail here
listen I was saying look here we have
the uh rings on the top and they have
magnets so let's get rid of the magnet
that's troubling him that's bothering
him so that it doesn't enter a fear with
his understanding we get rid of the
magnet this fellow is saying that that
rain okay is going around uh without the
magnet that he can have the Rings
without a magnet that there's Nano
they're not tied to anything he's saying
Okay
um
essentially this is what I showed
earlier okay and you can see there uh
that he's saying that those lines of
force that are around the magnet which
are now around two magnets for some
reason he's saying those are rings that
stand alone okay that's his argument
and so let's look at this
this show him that he why he is
not wrong he's irrational okay here here
we see it side by side so you can see it
okay so let's look at it in uh close up
here we're saying that what what you're
seeing now on the magnet is the same
thing that you see in two live wires
which he said are different he's saying
look at the patterns are different no
they're exactly the same the one on the
left the one with the lines that's a
magnet and the one on the right those
those two on the bottom there on the
bottom right those two are the two live
wires that's electricity going through
two live wires and what's happening
they're conducting current in opposite
directions okay and again you see the uh
pattern of uh squeezing uh water out of
a shirt you know the the how we used to
dry in the old days the two rollers and
that's what you're seeing there the two
rollers are working in in opposite
direction one is going clockwise the
other one counterclockwise and what
they're doing they're squeezing and
everything between them okay that's
what's happening there and that's the
same thing you see in a magnet what the
magnet uh does when the lines go inside
the magnet they're squeezing they're
bumping up one line of force against
line of force of the bottom part so a
magnet is not divided into South and
North it's divided into top and bottom
okay the the lines of force or really
the threads are swinging in the top in
One Direction and swinging in the bottom
of the magnet in the opposite direction
and what they're doing is they're
squeezing in the center of the magnet
right there in the middle of the magnet
they're squeezing what you see on the
right you're you're the two uh rollers
are going in opposite direction
essentially isn't that also how they do
the colliders at CERN where they
essentially have a whole bunch of these
until they squeeze the particle down to
us do exactly where they want it because
they use yeah yeah yeah isn't it
basically yeah
it's a circular pattern around uh the
where the um beam line the main beam to
get that beam line in the center
essentially they use this pattern
exactly only 360. instead of just two
they have one yeah they're pushing the
beam inwards but you can see they're on
the top right what's happening you see
the one on the top is clockwise the one
on the bottom is counterclockwise and
what's happening there the threads if
you put those together the threads are
going to be bumping against the ones
that from the top with the ones on the
bottom and they're going to squeeze like
you see at the bottom there you're going
to squeeze anything in between them to
the left the more you you try to get
them together the more they're gonna the
lines are gonna squeeze so what you're
staring at here is not uh that uh these
lines of force are circular uh they're
rings they're Standalone hula hoops no
what they're doing you have something
swinging in that region and it's pushing
the iron filings together against each
other that's what it's doing okay so uh
we have a different uh explanation for
all this than what you see out there
today and all all we ask is that you try
to understand it okay if you understand
it fine you're we're done we achieved
our goal whether you believe or not uh
you know if you got a better mouse trap
be my guest you know all I can do is
share mine with you
and visualize it at least yeah okay
here's another fellow and he asked about
the lunar arranging okay
lunar ranging you could have saved
yourself the embarrassment of looking
like an idiot if you had bothered to do
some research first phase 16 section 3.4
second paragraph in
yeah now there's a reference okay but
one must intention this is quoted from
that uh paper but one must intentionally
Point ahead of the lunar reflector to
where it will be in 1.25 seconds while
looking behind the current position of
the reflector to where it was 1.25
seconds ago yeah and what are we saying
here we're saying that
um uh this is what I was saying uh look
if I would have uh read that paper I
would have saved myself to trouble okay
of uh saying that um
as I saw a minute ago that the laser it
has to be pointed to where the Retro
reflector on the moon is going to be
in one second and in one second the
Earth moved and the moon moved both okay
and and you know remember the lasers
coming out of the Earth
right so the the thing is moving and we
moved 30 kilometers around the Sun in
that one second the moon moved one
second uh one kilometer with respect to
the Earth so we moved 30 kilometers the
moon moved one kilometer with respect to
us because the Moon is essentially going
faster than the earth because it's you
take the speed of the earth plus the
Earth the orbit of the moon okay the
moon runs circles around us okay so uh
the guy is saying well yeah they do
point it to where uh the moon is going
to be in one second so you should have
saved yourself the trouble well we got a
little problem let me tell you what the
problem is here let's look at this in
little detail okay here's uh here's the
moon okay and we're going deep yeah I
know what the Moon looks like okay but
we're gonna go the more is uh three and
a half million I put it in in
meters so that we're we all do it in
meters and we can see the relations here
okay it's three and a half million more
or less okay uh in diameter in meters in
diameter okay
they point the laser okay uh to uh where
it's approximately uh what is it six
kilometers okay they they do a raster
they they look for it so it's it's the
bean up there is about two kilometers
remember this this being diverges when
it comes out of the earth okay
yeah it is a cone it doesn't say like uh
uh a pinpoint that remember light
always diverges to some degree and even
a laser diverges giving enough time
length yeah okay so what happens the the
laser is diverging remember it comes out
of this it's a very powerful laser to be
able to shine it on the moon doesn't
have the little laser we use at home
would it be bad to look into that laser
well yeah yeah probably you get a
headache
so so the laser pointed at the moon but
look at where it's pointed it's pointed
at that little region I don't know if
you can see it in yellow I put it in
yellow okay and uh the Retro reflector
see the the region is six and a half
kilometers
6500 meters
and the Retro reflector is one meter
okay let's understand the latest area of
affected so what they're doing is
they're shooting and they're saying it's
somewhere in there and where do they
point to they point to a region they
know the crater they look at the crater
because they can see that more or less
with their telescope okay and they can't
see the the the little uh retro
reflector but they say we're going to
hit it somewhere around there why don't
we get a bean back we know we hit the
Retro reflector
that's how it's done okay let's let's
make sure we understand the process here
how they do the lunar ranging experiment
right right not only that collector is
super small but it's in a crater that
they kind of know where it is yeah and
they so they they bombard the area with
light until they get a reflection back
yeah and here you can see uh just just
again for reference this is all
reference here's the scoby and the Smith
craters and they're 40 kilometers apart
and that's the picture they took but
they take these pictures usually from
the like you see there on the right the
lunar we're gonna reconnaissance Orbiter
and that's orbiting the moon so we have
a Orbiter going around there and it
takes pictures and these are the best
pictures we can get from the Moon uh
today if you do it from a telescope here
on Earth well you can see the one on the
bottom right you see them from a little
farther away and that's a good telescope
there okay so you know it's not like you
can locate these things from the Earth I
mean you cannot see a matchbox from the
earth okay and much less uh I can't say
much less but you can't see the Retro
reflector which is two-thirds of a meter
times one meter which is about two feet
by three feet a little bigger than that
you can't see that from the earth they
don't know where the mirror is they
don't know they know it's somewhere in
the in that crater and so what they do
they shoot in that they shoot the laser
in that region in a 6.5 kilometer wide
uh region it's a two kilometer raster
that scans that whole region because
they can't hit it exactly and the only
reason they know they hit it is because
they get some photons back they get
according to them they get 21 photons
back
I said it right 21 photons that's so
they send gazillions up they said I
don't know how many billions out and you
only get 21 back that's the signal
that's how fate the signal is that is
detected here on Earth and the computer
uh you know maps that they say oh you
got to Peak we we hit the Retro
reflector that's how it's done so they
don't know what they're doing okay they
just uh get those signals and based on
that they say Okay
um uh how are we going to explain this
and the way they explain it is that
photography they're using photons are
going to the Moon a lot of them get lost
some hit the Retro reflector others hit
the crater and who knows what a rock and
those that hit the Retro reflector a lot
of them come back and only a few of
those are captured by our detector here
on Earth that's their explanation okay
and here's how the paper that this
fellow referenced the Murphy's paper we
can call it Murphy's Law okay
and I'm just going to put to the main
point here it says because none of the
reflectors are directly visible from the
ground okay he says that up front we
must rely on local topic topographical
features whose centers are well defined
we Center under reference crater okay so
they look at the Creator say oh there's
the Creator so the Retro reflector has
to be around here okay that's that's the
way they do it okay we execute a one Arc
suck okay which is a a little less than
two thousand uh uh two kilometers okay
so if you look at two kilometers uh
that's what an arc second is on the moon
that at that distance okay that's the
length spiral raster pattern around the
nominal position to pick up the signal
okay and when you go to the Wikipedia it
gives you a little more detail uh
summary essentially at the moon's
surface the beam is about 6.5 kilometers
four miles four miles wide scientists
liken the task of aiming the beam to
using a rifle to hit a moving dime three
kilometers away okay or 1.9 miles the
reflected light is too weak to see with
a human eye no kidding out of 10 to the
21 photons aimed at the reflector only
one is received back on Earth even under
good conditions this is what they're
doing okay now what is the problem
Murphy and his paper and uh these people
the first thing you have to understand
is Murphy works for NASA
and this group that's the problem so you
have the situation of the wolf guarding
the Sheep okay you have the fox Gardener
hands and so they have to produce a
report because they can't just go out
there do an experiment and we failed no
not only fail but say nothing they must
say something they must explain how they
spent the funds so they have to write a
paper they have to explain what they did
and that's what they try to do in their
paper they try to explain what they did
what are the problems here's the here's
where we arrive at the problems and that
this uh Miss completely and they're the
assumptions that uh he operates under
okay and these are the assumptions that
Murphy and his crew remember they're all
relativists they're all mechanics
quantum mechanics assumptions underlying
the lunar ranging experiment space is
equal to a physical object they treat
space as a physical object general
relativity traits it treats it as such
even though space is nothing
okay so they have space time and they
turn that into a four-dimensional
physical object uh Earth weighs down
this space okay it warps it and moon
does the same thing okay light what is
light mediated by beads they're thinking
of particles so they think that when
they shoot the laser they're shooting a
bunch of little photons along warp space
they're rolling marbles on a we got the
rolling marbles okay
uh the beeps travel one way and
rectilinearly supposedly but because
that's what Ray reversibility says but
they say but if you're gonna incorporate
warp space from space-time you know from
general relativity then you have a
curvature
okay so the little marbles are rolling
down this this uh incline because
remember the the moon Rose around the
earth because space is Warped around the
Earth just like both of them roll around
the sun because that means because uh
you know space is Warped by the sun okay
that's the explanation and so if the
moon it belongs to literally these are
just metaphors if if the moon is rolling
around the earth because the the Earth
is like a roulette you know bent space
the photons are rolling around that
space as well they don't travel straight
they also according to general
relativity not that I'm inventing this
but the photons roll around space
remember uh what is what how do the
photons from a star that's behind the
Sun come to our eyes when there's an
eclipse they roll around the Sun through
the worst space caused by the sun right
so the photons roll around warp space we
have to factor all this stuff in there
okay remember all this okay Photon beads
follow the curvature of War space and so
it's the theory that they put forth they
say gazillions of photon beads go out
and only handful come back okay fine
what is what is the issue here the issue
is
um here's the round trip that's a huge
root of this yeah so here we have the
photons going from Earth to the Moon the
Moon moved and so did the Earth and then
they come back okay this is what they're
saying uh I I drew too many coming back
okay it should have been gazillions
going out and
a handful coming back okay but uh we
have warp space how did they hit the uh
the Retro reflector with large space Not
only do they have to shoot in front but
they have to shoot in such a way
back no not only that they have to
factor uh the work space and the
question is how warped the space from
Earth to the Moon I mean do they have
that calculation well so first
understand this the first step would be
without workspace is this akin to
throwing a ball against the wall so that
you catch it again
see what you got to do is you got to
think of it as a tobo gun you know uh
the slide at the park it's curb right
more or less okay so you're rolling the
ball along a curve right and the Moon is
moving also sideways yeah so not only is
it rolling how are you going to
calculate where you're going to hit
the moon if you've got this curvature of
space-time first you know the little
marbles are going to roll down there
then the moon is going to move the Earth
is going to move as well so you're going
to get them back through sort of the
same curvature right
uh good luck with all that I think it's
uh overly complicated it involves
Concepts which are reified like you know
space time just it involves Zero
Dimensional photons but they don't do
any of that yeah but I know but they
they name and shoot exactly and if they
do that that means there is no our space
and if they shoot it in front remember I
mean in front they just nuke the area
with light don't they not only that but
it's important to note see I I made a
little video there showing that the Moon
is gonna be over here remember we're
only talking about maybe 70 kilometers
so so uh they don't have to shoot out in
the middle of space like I showed you my
picture I just exaggerated that the
point is they have to shoot in front
where the moon is going to be uh in one
second which is 70 kilometers down the
road Maybe okay so they don't have the
point at the crater they would have to
point where the Creator is going to be
yeah but I mean one second isn't that
much
yeah exactly that's not much you know
but 70 kilometers means you can't point
to the crater they're saying they're
pointing at the crater yeah but how can
you point at the Creator if the Creator
is no longer there
that's my point but how fast is it going
yeah when one kilometer and the Earth
moved 30 kilometers in that one second
so the Earth is moving the Moon is
moving and they're saying they're gonna
shoot that laser you know
where the where the moon is going to be
in one second which is going to be down
the road obviously the Earth is also
going to move we're talking about two
and a half seconds so you're talking
about uh 650 but 750
000 kilometers right
uh three hundred thousand yeah 750 000
kilometers in round trip uh for the
photon yeah okay and so where are you
going to shoot your Beam at are you
gonna shoot it at the crater you can't
because the crater is no longer there
the crater already moves
though in second though
70 kilometers that means where's your
where are you focusing if I mean if it
stoods if everything Stood Still you say
okay I focus on the crater yeah and I'm
there but if light takes just to see it
forget about the laser just to see the
moon just to see the crater it took one
second to reach it the Moon is no longer
there but a moon is but it's not no
longer there it's just shifted by one
second so so where are you so where are
you gonna shoot this telescope just to
tell us forget about the link yeah let's
let's just keep this there still for now
yeah and we'll move the the moon one
second that's negligible
that's uh one kilometer away
buddy about a 70 kilometer area so yeah
but remember the Earth is moving 30
kilometers and it's also moving around
not without the Earth yeah but it's just
to hit the the mirror is the one second
is negligible can we agree on that
assuming the Earth Stood Still and the
moon was going
pretty much there because it's 70
kilometers if you're if you're circled
there you're gonna hit on the moon is 70
kilometers and it just moves one
it's basically the same thing yeah it's
like it's it's not the same thing it's
that again what they do is that's why
they have to shoot a rest or they they
shoot a big region
that's that's a big problem with this
whole thing was that you can't really
talk about precise measurements because
they're basically just nuking the area
until they hit something my argument is
that uh the two assumptions are what are
wrong that light consists of particles
discrete particles little balls and uh
space time is worked yeah it kills those
two quantum mechanics and general
relativity in one shot or else they
would have to factor those because yeah
because they don't because uh well they
do to some degree but it's I mean what
is the curvature of space I mean have
they figured out how much curvature is
required for the moon to go around and
if the if you have to calculate that you
know that the Earth has to be weighing
the uh canvas yeah very deep for the
moon not to fly away for it to find this
wall and along that same curvature the
photons are going to be falling in there
and so you get this curvature very
pronounced curvature that's not what
they do they shoot it directly at the
Moon are the phone are they when they
point at the crater forget about the
Retro reflector where they point at the
crater are they pointing downwards to
them I mean what is this not everybody
directly and it's a straight line
essentially is the straight line it
should not be a straight line if spaces
work yes it's like bowling by throwing
the ball straight at the pins instead of
along the floor yeah imagine imagine
your voice
now imagine you're bullying and the the
uh field is curved yeah but but they
just ignore that and they just throw
straight at the pins they're throwing it
straight at the pins but if relativity
is correct it should be going your your
bowling ball should be yeah
suddenly essentially rolling these uh
marbles up because
they're not they're shooting directly at
the moment and how do you how are you
going to explain that except that you
are instantaneously essentially right
from our point of view 300 000
kilometers away but still it's
essentially a straight line because if
there is curvature of space time that
thing should be a total a very deep
curve not only a curvature it's very
deep for the moon not to fly away
see and they don't explain that that
they treat all these things separately
and it's like nobody puts them together
that's my point
okay anyways um here's uh some more
issues here uh fellow says
uh they represent the past of electron
he's saying that the magnetic lines of
force are electrons
yeah yeah wait one ring is an electron
going around or what no no he's saying
the lines of force there that you see in
the magnet first let's look at the
magnet on the top okay he's saying that
those lines of force are made are
electrons but but it's a chain of
electrons or one electron going around
yeah I'm assuming he's saying it's a
chain of electrons he's saying there's
gazillions of electrons moving in that
in those lines that those lines are
electrons that's what he's saying is
essentially so they represent the paths
of electrons in different circumstances
you can build an apparatus you know he
doesn't explain much more than that he
just says you can build an apparatus
using the uh read sensor uh out of a
hard drive to detect the individual
electrons moving along these magnetic
field line
and I'm saying that people who still do
physics with particles they have to be
mentally okay they have to be
mentally because we have not
been able to explain anything in the
last ten thousand years with particles
the universe doesn't work with particles
but discrete particles you can't explain
it you can't explain how two particles
which are separated yeah how did they do
push how do they do pull push is easy no
no they're separated oh foreign please
do push or pull right there explain that
just two Barnacles you got the string
here yeah
well then you can do that
here you have two particles we have
space in between nothing in between and
you want to put gazillions of particles
go ahead and do it but we just need two
of them how does this particle affect
this one from a distance whether push or
pull that's all you got to explain
the day you can explain that no math no
equation we don't need any of that we
just need a physical mechanism how does
this particle affect this particle if
they're not even touching each other if
all particles in the universe are
isolated how does one particle affect
another so no you cannot explain push or
pull the only two forces we're aware of
except in Quantum they have four forces
four horses uh and then you know there
you have your atom if the electron like
this individual says is a discrete
particle explain your atom show me your
atom show me how that electron doesn't
fly away what keeps it bound to the
proton again
specific it's the same issue why does it
go in that specific what do you call it
it's the orbital yeah energy
yeah they call them energy but
assuming that each one of these lines of
force each ring light a forest okay or
one at one electron sorry going around
why does the electron follow that
specific uh yeah again what and the same
thing with the electron on the bottom
why does it follow I mean you know you
don't have to even have an orbit because
the current version is that the electron
jumps uh anywhere in within that yellow
region yeah great fine it's not going
around I just want to know why that
electron what stops it from flying away
spontaneously or from falling to the
nucleus that's what you got to explain
and same thing uh what Anza said about
the magnet if the electron if it's
electrons going through those lines
don't tell me how to detect them tell me
how
visualize for me make a movie of how
that electron goes around and why it
does that is it tied somehow to the
magnet with a little string yeah is that
why it goes around it's going it's going
through a specific very specific uh
organ yeah you gotta explain why it does
that don't tell me that it does we know
that it does the question is how we
don't know what it does well I mean what
could you assume that it does we'll
concede what this guy says
yeah why would it that's all you got to
explain once you get that further away
that closer and again it's irrational
people who who enter it's not irrational
it's it's conclusive that's a better
word one fellow says uh What uh what are
you going to address Matt Parker also
known as stand up Mass
uh yeah fellow does comedy and he does
mathematics I don't do either some
people say mine is all comedy
okay uh but you know here we try to do
science this guy doesn't do science he
does he's just a guy who's out there
doing uh stand up comedy using math as
his subject matter so he entertains
people no no nothing wrong but I mean
he's not a scientist he doesn't do
science he does math math is not science
description I mean yeah he does no he
does maintain yeah he does math he does
uh all uh things uh quirky things
related to math you know interesting
things and he just makes fun of them and
so that was fun yeah so no problem but I
mean he's in a different line of
business than I am I'm into explaining
mechanisms physics and he's into
descriptions mathematical descriptions
and uh making jokes out of them
we're a little different uh
yeah we have um math is real we are made
of math yeah so being hasenfelder and
she says math history we are made of
math and you go into that video she just
put it up the other day and she says the
following the things that I thought was
important it's got to do with the word
exists existence and that's where we
have the problem what what is real and
she addressed that issue essentially and
she says in physics something is real
because it's a good explanation for our
observations
but remember what did she say it's a
good explanation
she uses the word explanation
she continues we can't actually see
Elementary particles with our eyes we
say they are real because certain
mathematical structures describe
our observations
this lady doesn't know the difference
between an explanation and a description
she just uses these words
interchangeably
and no in all of mathematics you will
not find a single explanation all you'll
find is descriptions math can only
describe but she uses the word
explanation when it's very clear that
mathematical physics cannot explain
anything involving
um invisible entities it doesn't have a
rational explanation for anything and
she says if you see three apples three
describes what you see yeah therefore
it's real the three is real yeah that's
what you say it's real because uh three
is a number is the word the number the
whatever that we use to describe she's
saying the word the the concept three is
real yeah and uh she says if that's the
notion of reality that you don't want to
use I challenge you to come up with a
different notion that is consistent and
agrees with how most people use the word
right we don't care how people use the
word we don't care because science is
not about voting and saying I like this
definition we don't care if all of
humanity votes for the same definition
for the Flat Earth depends on mother
nature mother nature laughs at uh he
humans that are wrong about that it's
it's how you want to use the word no
it's it's talking about the notion of
reality if you use the word reality for
one way and I use it for another
now in science we don't have different
Notions of reality the way we do it we
get inside the ring we fight and only
one man remains standing that doesn't
make sense yeah we cannot have two
different our words you define your word
but you got to defend your definition if
someone shoots your definition and tears
it to Pieces you're gonna say well I'm
going to use it anyways yeah the word
object people say it's see and touch
that's the criteria no we can easily
demonstrate that an object is not that
which you can see and touch that's not
an object not for the purposes of
physics of Science in ordinary speech
that's an object not in science in
science you got to defend that
definition and I'm saying you can't see
or touch the table that's on the other
side of this planet the Chinese table
over there I can't see or touch it so is
that table not an object is the word
table doesn't it refer to an object so
clearly the Criterion is not C and touch
and he who brings the C touch Criterion
is is uh I don't care if everybody votes
for it it doesn't make it true because
of that mother nature laughs at that
person
no in object is that which has shaped
all objects have shape it's a universal
property not all objects can be touched
not all objects can be seen now we have
a definition we can use in science you
don't like my definition it's not you go
ahead and do your thing no no get inside
the ring and fight if you want to do
science defend your definition and
attack mine that's the way it is I like
how she sees three apples and she says
the apples are real and the three is
real what yeah the three is real yeah
sorry you lost me on that second one yes
so this is the way we Define it in
science we say exist physical presence
an object is that which has shape and
exists is an object that has location if
it doesn't have location it's an object
yes but that doesn't exist
more or less like that foe in the center
there you know he's an object but he
doesn't exist location he's right there
right there yeah if I can put God uh you
know this is the dude and Rose no no no
that's God that's uh Michelangelo's got
come on yeah don't you recognize God
when you see him
yeah God I love God you know he's my
found God on the
cornerstone so uh we have any issues
there no we got most of them okay folks
there are more answers to your homework
questions of extinctions there seems to
be more of a interesting subject to
people yeah yeah well you want to know
how they're going to die they don't want
to know about aiming a laser at the Moon
which is also cool but yeah those are
details that kind of go under okay then
we'll see you next time